here to tell us more about the
possibilities of wind power is an expert
on flow dynamics from Berlin's Technical
University Christian Oliver push right
thank you very much for being with us
today all right how realistic is the
idea of wind powered cars after that
last report I must say I personally am
skeptical well going against the wind
using a wind turbine is completely
realistic I have no doubt that this will
work however if we will see wind
turbines on cars to go on our streets
there have also doubts about that all
right let's talk about some of the
things you brought today this is a blade
from a turbine can you explain what
these this is a model of a wind turbine
blade and this I would like to use to
explain a bit about our research so we
try to control flows too many people
late flow so that the flow does what we
want so we use it for example to reduce
drag we use that capability to enhance
mixing and to increase lift and this is
exactly the problem of a wind turbine
blade what you see here are float aft
switch are glued on to the blade and
they indicate us where the flow is still
attached to the blade because if the
flow detaches then you lift you loose
your lift and on an airplane this would
mean you just fall to the ground you
don't have anymore lift which holds you
in the air on the new wind turbine this
means if this happens that we have a
decreased capability of using the wind
power to convert this into electrical
energy so if the float aft are showing
this direction we have still the flow
attached if it shows in this direction
the flow is detached and then we use a
little devices like this one here this
is a vortex generator so this creates
stream-wise vertex and this vortex
transports fluid from the outer side to
the blade and in this way the flow is
capable of staying attached to the blade
does not detached has the lift and there
converts more wind energy into
electrical energy all right now we know
that Germany has set itself a goal of
getting 45 percent of its electricity
from renewable sources how much of that
will come from wind energy
well definitely wind will play a major
role on that share specifically like
going offshore we are building large
wind turbines offshore but there are
still many many problems to be solved
which are like going offshore means you
would like to have an installation which
is quite big has a diameter which is
larger than an Airbus a380 and these
large blades need modern methods of flow
control to react for example to changing
wind speeds to avoid separation like
explained before all right well we're
gonna have to leave it there for now but
we thank you very much for that
interesting discussion on wind energy
it's John Oliver push right